Debbie starts off this hour in Reno
Nevada
hi Debbie how are you good how can I
help you well I just finished your you
know the the clap wanted my husband to
take it with me he refused he said that
our money issues were all my fault and
so me and my sister ticket and it did us
we both really got a lot out of it but
my question is how do I get him on board
with managing our money so why does he
say any money issues are all your fault
well I made about a car that I shouldn't
have if I take in your class I would not
but you know now we're upside down in it
so I can't really sell it at this moment
but it was an impulse buy I admit it
I've apologized for it for six months
now and he just she says okay I want to
manage the money
oh I said here it all is here's and he
won't even have a budget meeting yeah
okay
what else did you do other than my car
impulsively what else what what else did
you do other than by a car impulsively
you know that that would be it
so one thing that was one time in our 24
years of marriages and so all of a
sudden you are not due to have a say-so
anymore in your marriage at all
apparently yes that would be my best
guess you don't have a money problem you
have a marriage problem yeah we don't
communicate about marriage very I mean
money very well you know why I did about
a lot of things very well well probably
yeah and he's extremely disgusted with
you over this over this car thing and
probably over a pattern of things over
the years having to do with money and
and you're now trying to turn things
around but he won't even give you the
time of day on respect and so that
that's a major problem because you're
gonna eventually become disgusted with
that I will tell you having done what I
do for 25 years that if you guys don't
get marriage counseling that I would say
you're probably heading for the cliff
well I am pretty disgusted yeah and he
is too right and so that's why the only
person that you got to find some common
ground and you got to be safe willing to
forgive some things and then prove some
things meaning earn some trust back the
way you would only trust back would be
working together with him on a budget
following the things you learned in the
class and then the way he would earn
trust back would be to actually start to
count his wife's vote in these things
he's not a benevolent dictator you don't
get that right and yet he's acting and
yet he's acting like one yeah
however you went impulse to freaking car
and that might have got me in that mood
but you've apologized you said hey I
went to class I'm learning something
different let's try something new
together and and he's like and he's
basically flipping you off at that point
right I said okay
what we're doing isn't working yeah and
he said oh you're right but we've tried
this before I suggest that we never put
the work into it we just you know kind
of like you said we were kind of
fumbling along so I said now we have
some guidelines we have support we have
the website and all the explanation yeah
so are you guys in a church by chance no
okay I was going to refer you there to
find a good counselor find a good find a
good friend that's in a good church that
can refer you towards a marriage
counselor I'll give you a prediction
he's going to say that your marriage
problems are your fault too and he
doesn't need marriage counseling you
should go right you should go anyway
without him and begin to talk to the
marriage counselor on how to draw him in
to the marriage again and then you can
draw him into the money again but you're
going to need some coaching to do that
more than a radio guy okay and because
if you don't drawing to this marriage
counseling table eventually one of you
is going to completely melt down the
rest of the way and you're going to end
this thing and I don't want that to
happen I go
I want you guys to save this it's 24
years you need to say right yeah you
need to need to be to less selfish
people less bitter people and come back
together based on even in spite of the
past of the way he's treated you and the
dumb things you've done in spite of
those things you come back together and
say okay we're gonna turn over a new
leaf
clean slate start afresh and so on like
we do with a lot of things it's it's
forgiveness and reconciliation and we're
gonna land together on how we're gonna
do things from this point forward and so
yeah you need to go see a marriage
counselor sooner rather than later this
is why I don't recommend that people
take Financial Peace University without
their spouse because what it generally
does is it makes them matter at their
spouse not less mad Financial Peace
University is actually a detriment to
your marriage if you take it without
your spouse very seldom does that work
and I'm not saying she did a bad thing
by going I'm just saying if you ever
hear me tell people not to take it
without their spouse that's why because
it drives a wedge further and tighter
into the in-between this relationship
and and you get more and more and more
disgusted you you more and more and more
are proud of where you are Debbie and
can see a bright future but he doesn't
have that new information and so he
doesn't believe in the new you at all
and and you're getting madder and madder
and madder at him for that and both of
you are right to have these feelings but
you really got to deal with them big
time big time
so don't get to a marriage counselor
within the next week or so please as
soon as you can and get started on that
and if he doesn't go go without him but
tell him you know that were I'm afraid
our marriage is gonna end because I'm
about to end it I'm about sick of you
and we need to get some help so that we
don't lose this thing hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my
my own youtube channel yes that's right
it's kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you